طيب من اليوم ورايح نصيحه ما عاد تطرده
اذا حسيته حالكم عندكم شعور بالملل اكيد
عم تسالوا حالكم ليش لانه دراسه نشرتها
صحيفه الفرنسيه كشفت انه الاحساس بالملل
اللي بيشوفوك طار احساس قاتل وخطير هو
فعليا وبحسب هذه الدراسه بالعكس الدراسه
بتقول انه شعور بالملل عنده كثير من
الفوائد لاسيهما على الصحه العقليه
للانسان سبحان الله دراسه الطبيه النفسيه
اللي عملت في فرنسا استاندات على الشيء
اللي يعاشوا الفرنسيين خلال فتره العزل
الصحي ووقت امتزم الكل بيوتهم الصحيفه
الفرنسيه قالت كمان انه الناس بفتره الحجر
استفادوا من كثير اشياء منها انه اكتر
قرروا يرجعوا يقراوا كتبهم او كتب هن
كانوا حابين انهم يقراوها وغيرهم اختار
انه يتعلم لغات جديده الطبيب النفسي بتاعه
شركه
احنا بالملل عقلنا حاله او لوحده راح يصير
وكانه بطير وراح تنفتح الفجوات ما بين
دماغ الايمن والايسر ويمكن انه يظهر وميض
العبقريات والله بصراحه انا لقيتها هي
خبريه حلوه كثير وعموما الموضوع مكمل يا
جماعه لانه وفقا لاغلب الباحثين في علم
النفس وعلم الاجتماع في فرنسا والولايات
المتحده الملل بعزز الابداعات تخيلوا
الدليل انه دراسه طبيه نفسيه امريكيه نشرت
عام 2014 اظهرت نفسيا عملت لاربعين شخص
اظهر وابداعات اكثر بعد خضوعم الاختبارات
ممله جدا جدا ومن اللي كثير على ما يبدوه
الحمد لله هلا احنا صار عندنا حجه نقنع
حالنا فيها على الاقل
ومعنا شيء نعمله ولكن حتى نفهم اكثر عن
هذه الدراسه معنا الان من عمان
الدكتوره رشا التميمي اخصائيه الطب النفسي
اهلا فيك يا دكتوره رشا معنا في تفاعلكم
يعني هو يقال بانه الحاجه ام الاختراع
ففعلا لما نكون احنا نشعر بالملل ينطبق
هذا المثل مثلا وبالتالي بنصير احنا بحاجه
الى اي نوع من انواع الترفيه حتى لو ما
كان هذا الشيء متوفر الينا من خلال
التلفزيون شاشه التلفزيون او ال- اا
السوشيال ميديا او التليفونات راح همم
نخترع شيء لحتى يرفه عن نفسه
يسعد مساك
المشاهدين جميعا اهلا وسهلا اهلا فيك في
البدايه همم هم يقصد فيهم اكثر مش حاله
الملل بيوضح ان الشعور الملل انه شعور
الذي يعني فيه الانسان الضجر
حاله السكون اللي بيمر فيها العاقل يعني
الحاله اللي ما بيكون فيها الانسان همم
يعني مضغوط عنده احتراق نفسي وجسدي من كثر
المهام التي يضعها على نفسه سواء انها
عمليه لها علاقه بالمهنه اولها علاقه
بالاسره ولا علاقه همم الارتباطات
الاجتماعيه حاله السكون اللي بامر فيها
العقل هي حاله مطلوبه وفريده منه نوعها
وهي همم يعني يمكن هلا يستغربوا عدد من
المشاهدين هي حاله مطلوبه علاجيه ترتبط
بما يسمى باليقظه الذهنيه
احنا بنستعد نستخدمه كاخصائيه علاج جد
سلوكي همم من اجل راحه العقل ومن اجل صفاء
وحتى يكون زي ما ذكرتي همم قادر اكثر اكثر
قابله على الانتاج وعلى الابتكار
الموضوع اتعقد كثير بصراحه دكتوره وانا
كنت مبسوطه انه يعني مش لازم احس بالذنب
مثلا اذا اولادي ضلوا يقولوا زهقانين او
احنا نشعر بالملل ضجرانين وانا ما يعني ما
همم عملت لهم اي نوع من انواع الترفيه
يعني لازم احس لازم احس بالذنب ولا لا
هو هو عدم فعل شيء
هو عمل لا تقوم باي عمل هو انت ذهنيا
بتقومي بعمل فعليا انت بتقومي اما بتامل
بامر معين او انت بتقومي بممارسه حتى لو
شيء بسيط بيديك وممارسه التخيل شيء عمر
سعيد او او ذكرى سعيده او حتى تخيل شيء
همم سوف تقومين في المستقبل فهذا مجرد
القيام فيه عمل ولكنه عمل ذهني يرتبط بشكل
كبير بصفاء الدهن طب دكتور انا كنت عم
تتحدث فيه عن السكون الدهني او السكون
بيحس انه العقل مش مشغول
بكتير من يا الواجبات يا اما الخطط يا اما
شو ما كان يكون وهون ممكن انه يكون في
مساحه للابداع طب مش ممكن انه او بعديها
بيكون في مساحه للابداع مش ممكن انه هاي
الفتره تطول فبالتالي ندخل في حاله سكون
فبيصير الملل مضاعف يعني هيك حاله ومش
عارفين خروج منه
طبعا هلا بده يكون في محادين للموضوع لانه
انا اقوم بهذا ال همم اقوم بهذا النشاط
الدهني او او الاسترخاء الدهني او السكون
الدهني ليس بقصد اضرار الافكار السلبيه او
سمح الله يعني المشاعر السلبيه والذكريات
السيئه غالبا بتكون في الماضي او الابحاث
المستقبل بقدر ما هي انه عيش اللحظه هنا
والامن نعيشها هنا والان بالعكس هي هي
ليست انفصال عن الواقع هي هي فعليا هي
الواقع ذاته انا اعيش اللحظه كما هي ولكن
بدون همم ارهاق نفسي بانشطه اخرى عيش
اللحظه همم كما هي يعني انا بنصح كثير من
المراجعين بحكي لهم عيشوا همم وقتك انت
مين تايم يعني خصص وقت لنفسك انت وهو لا
باس اذا ما كنت بتعمل فيه ولا شيء لا بس
هذا بحدها شيء
يعني الدراسه عملات في فرنسا واخدت يعني
كمثال اللي صار في وقت كورونا وهذا الشيء
لا ينطبق على فرنسا فقط ولكن على العالم
اجمع كلنا التزمنا ببيوتنا في فتره الحجر
وكنا اضطرينا انه نلاقي بدائل همم الروتين
اليومي اللي احنا كنا همم متعودين عليه هل
يعني هل كل نقدر نقول انه البشريه كلها
عاده اكتشاف نفسها وعنها واكتشاف عائلتها
لانه عندنا مع بعض في البيت في فتره كرونه
فبالتالي همم وصلنا لهذه المرحله من
السكون فعلا
ما هي عدد كبير من الاشخاص يعني حتى
الكورنه حملت معها سلبيات صحيه وسلبيات
اقتصاديه لا شك هذا الامر ولكن حملت معها
ايضا كثير من الايجابيات الكثير اعدد
اكتشاف نفسه عاد اكتشاف صفاته
وزاد وعيون لنفسه ما يحب ما يكره لانه كان
فعليا في العمليه المهنيه منخرط في
العمليه الاجتماعيه بدون ان يضع نفسه اولا
حتى نفسه ما هي بحاجه له وتم اكتشاف كمان
الزوج لزوجته والزوجه لزوجها على بعض بهاي
الفتره ولقينا شغلات بدنا نعملها شكرا
جزيلا لك يا دكتوره رشا التميمي اخصائيه
الطب النفسي شكرا
[موسيقى]